the phantom troop continues to wreak
havoc on the streets of york new city
karapiga gets permission to patrol the
building while patrolling members and
bosses of the mafia are seen unsatisfied
with their situation
kurapika then receives a call from gon
and killua but to tell korapika about
them being kidnapped by the phantom
troop which makes korapika angry at them
the two still insist on helping by
giving him information but koropika
refuses since he has another source and
doesn't want them to get involved in his
mission
the phantom troop continues the rampage
while getting near the auction building
a situation inside cemetery building is
uncontrollable in which the members of
the mafia start to panic and want to
protect themselves by breaking the rules
of the auction ceno and silva appear and
warn the mafia about a member of the
phantom troop who sneaked inside the
building making them realize how strong
he is by saying he can kill them all in
less than 10 seconds
karapika while trying to find the troop
gets a call from light who orders him to
go back to her daughter zeno and silva
finally find crowl's location and after
a short chat the three make their moves
and start to battle
crawlow manages to cut sola by using a
ben's knife which silva easily
recognizes and he managed to stop the
poison from spreading
zeno analyzes crawlows and abilities and
manages to deduce that crawler's power
because it is so powerful has an
activation cost of at least four or
maybe five conditions which crawlow is
very unlikely able to meet while
fighting both xeno and silva at the same
time citing that crawler's use of a
toxic knife is further evidence that
crawler cannot steal men abilities
freely this prompts crawlow realizing
zeno's skill based upon his analysis of
his power to discard the knife and
switch tactics
xeno walks towards crawler and makes his
move but he suddenly stops he sees
crawlow taking action by using his
ability a book that contains the lists
of abilities he stole
zeno becomes more cautious and uses his
nan to fight crawlow at a distance and
manages to guess the use of crawler's
book while fighting crawler captivating
xeno's attacks while not letting his
guard down on silva when crowler finally
felt the presence of silva he gets
distracted then caught in zeno's
technique when crawlow is finally
trapped zma signals sola to finish him
off and silva releases two large
illuminating balls of aura aimed
directly toward crawlow and his father
the lumi and koludo arrived to
assassinate the ten dons back in the
cemetery building the guests of the
auction field a huge explosion caused by
sola's attack on the basement as the
guest panic bean arrives and tells them
that the ten dollars will speak to them
directly the guests praised nostrad
fortune telling ability as they remain
safe during the whole event in the
auction hall the leader of the ten dons
appears on the screen and apologizes for
the inconvenience
informs everyone that the leader of the
phantom troop is dead and the rest will
soon be dealt with elsewhere the ten
dons are revealed to have been killed by
illumi he calls silva through their
transmitter and asks his father whether
his client crawlo is still alive
from the debris inside the basement zeno
and crawlow emerge with little damage
illumi tells silva to relay a message to
crawlow to write the payment to illumi's
account xeno returns to leave and when
crawlow asks why zeno explains that the
ten dons were their clients and now that
they are killed crawlow is not their
target anymore the zoldic family does
not kill for pleasure everything runs
because of business krovo expresses his
relief and asks again if they continue
their fight who would win
xeno confidently answers himself but if
crawlow has really decided on killing
him then that would be another matter
when zeno and silva have left crawlow
collapses on the floor and is
disappointed for not being able to steal
their abilities
karapika instructs melody to wait at the
hospital and they will send the straight
there the doctor assures everyone that
she has just fainted and will be safer
in the hospital the spiders arrive at
the basement to see crawlow he tells
cortopia to proceed with their plan to
make static copies of their corpses he
orders them not to hinder the ambulance
that no straight is in while on their
way a core applicator assures light that
no one will harm her the auction begins
and being gets a light from hisoka
backstage and is killed by machi the
host of the auction is controlled by
shalinar and pakunoda serves as the
bringer of the items the next item is
mentioned and in the backstage area the
original item is being replaced by
cortopi
the fake copy is introduced to the
audience to which the guests spent their
money on
as korapika watches the ambulance
leaving his approach by two men and they
ask him why is he not attending the
auction
korapika is informed that the leader of
the phantom troop is dead zenji taunts
kora pika over this and ends up getting
punched
karapika refuses to believe it unless he
has seen the body with his own eyes
crawlow's corpse is found outside by the
mafia they found the bodies of the other
five members karapika rushes back inside
the building and arrives just in time to
see the scarlet eyes being auctioned he
calls light and asks if he should bid on
them light orders that corapica must win
the scarlet eyes
he bids 350 million for the eyes but
zenji contradicts him once more bidding
one billion in the end the scarlet eyes
cost 2.9 billion
karapika gloomily walks back towards the
hospital carrying the scarlet eyes and
encounters zenji on the road the mafia
boss points a gun at him but korapika
threatens him and reveals his very own
scarlet eyes
zenji recoils in surprise and fear as
corepika walks past him now straight
awakens and is overjoyed at the sight of
the scarlet eyes
melody senses korat because sadness and
assures him he calls gome and informs
him about the spider's deaths meanwhile
hisoka attempts to call korapika but the
other line is not answering he watches
as the members of the troop drink over
the success of their mission gon kilua
korapika and lee oreo finally reunite in
your new city and have some words with
each other kur apikat explains his nen
powers to his friends and the sacrifices
he's made to become stronger kill lula
gets angry because he believes that a
member from the phantom troop who can
read memories is still alive
korapika also mentions teaming up with
hizoka who gave him some information
about the troop meanwhile crawlow orders
the troop to depart your new by night
nobody denies stating that they need to
find the chain user and avenge ubo's
death after franklin advises him to
follow their boss orders he starts
questioning if it was indeed an order
from their boss
he calls crawlow by his name and wants
to ask him a few questions crawler faces
him stating that before he answers his
questions he needs to first answer his
questions crollo asks nobody about his
date of birth blood type even his full
name and gives him a sheet of paper to
write all of his answers down
he then uses the technique he stole for
no straight to foretell nambianava's
future noganava's fortune states that
the phantom troop will lose more members
the passage is similar to crawler's own
fortune
shizuku asks kralov to foretell her
fortune too she deciphers the verses
with the help of crawlow and learns that
she is one of the members who will die
by next week along with shelnark and
pakinota
after learning the results the members
remind nobunaga they might get killed if
they keep on pursuing the chain user
crawlow also reminds him about his
position and value on the troop hisoka
jumps into the conversation and asks
crawlow if he can foretell the fortunes
of each member meanwhile korapika still
plans to collect the eyes of his clan
when suddenly he receives a message from
hisoka stating that the corpses were
fake it gets furious and overjoyed at
the same time
the situation has changed and gone
killua and lyorio want to aid their
friend
korapika receives a call from melody and
she says that the mafia has given up
hunting the phantom troop it was a
direct order from the ten dons the
awards have been rescinded for they
believe that the members of the troop
came from a place called meteor city the
members of the phantom troop have their
fortunes told by crawlow hisoka's
fortune is shown to be about meeting and
teaming up with koratpika and giving him
information about some of the phantom
troop members abilities it also
foreshadows when he will face crolo
alone pakinoda wants to see hisoka's
fortune but hizoka warns her she might
regret it on handing his fortune to her
it somehow changes after learning
hisoka's fortune pakinoda immediately
shows it to the others
after reading hisoka's fortune nobody
accuses him of selling out the phantom
troop to the chain user with sword drawn
novanyme gets no answer from hisoka who
sits calmly fiddling with his cards
shalonak and franklin try to settle him
down knowing the fortunes can be avoided
hisopa tells them that the first verse
with the chain user is true but after
that he can't explain the rest he'll
fight but only defend himself nobunaga
decides to attack who is teleported to
higher ground away from hisoka by
crawlow he himself asks kosoka a few
questions about the fortune but kisoka
does not say a word about his
relationship with kora pika
he analyzes the fortune further asking
which powers hisoka has seen from the
various troop members and deduces the
chain user's abilities one is to capture
and kill as he did with ubo and another
being to control what one says this
coming from the line sword of law and
hisoka's fortune
crawler believes this sword is pointed
towards hisoka's heart restricting his
speech hisoka naturally becomes aroused
at crawler's reasoning skills wanting to
kill him all the more they figure hisoka
will not be able to fight the chain user
because of this in his mind hisoka lasts
at them having fabricated most of his
fortune using his nen there's no sword
of law at his heart and he only revealed
ubo and shizuku's powers crawler's
decision is to stay in your new city
meanwhile killua decides not to pursue
the troop with gon
kilua believes the risk is too much now
without even a reward for their capture
but gohan still thinks it's the right
thing to do
kiluah reminds him they're there for
greed island and still need funds for it
gone has a plan but keeps it a secret
much to kill as annoyance so they can
continue stalking the troop the four sit
around coming up with a plan kilual will
stake out the troop base and kuratika
makes it clear their target will be
pakinoda liorio will be the driver for
korapika and gone will act as a decoy so
pakanota can be snatched away
to increase his resolve like korat
because gon asks for him to put a nen
blade next to his heart karapika accepts
but not before kiluah and lyorio pop up
from behind him and ask for the same men
blades
the blades can be taken away after the
mission is complete but korepika never
wanted to use the blades at all
he wanted to hear how serious the three
were about fighting the phantom troop
that they would go to such lengths to
help now that he knows he's glad he has
such good friends and thanks to them all
kilua leaves to the troop base so their
plan can begin
various troop members go over their
fortunes again many with unpleasant
predictions crawler puts them into
groups shizuku machi and pakinoda
kourtabi feiten and finx crollo shalnark
and nobunaga banalana franklin and
hisoka mashi mentions gon and killua to
crawlow reminding nobunaga he wanted
them recruited into the troop machi
tells crawlow she thinks they have
something to do with the chain user so
just as a precaution cortapi creates
multiple fake bases to throw them off
kiluau arrives to find 50 new identical
buildings gomiorio and corapica ride in
a car on a rainy day
kurapika contacts melody who is still
shopping with meon meanwhile the phantom
troupe discussed about korapika or as
they call him the chain user as well as
the nostrade family and the various
bodyguards protecting the girl they are
each even flyers with pictures of each
bodyguard crollo realizes after meeting
nostrade and stealing her powers he
could have gotten information from her
about korathika and the reason she's in
your new city he pieces together that
nostrade likes collecting body parts
like the scarlet eyes at the underground
auction
and that kora picada is also after the
eyes and revenge for his brethren the
troop looked through the boxes that were
stolen from the auction for the eyes
kortapi uses his powers by touching the
eyes to find the copy he created it
leads to the hotel where no strain and
company are staying nobody wants to go
immediately and crawler tells him he's
going to
on a roof killua stakes out the hideout
the best he can when he gets a call from
melody he learns of melody's amazing
ability to hear
kralo nobunaga shizuku kortopi machi and
pakinota make their way towards the
hotel
melody is instantly able to hear their
movements the two follow the troop as
gon calls killua for an update
the oreo drives them to a train station
the troop is headed to while melody and
killua ride on the same train
the troop exit the train and kurapika
informs squala they're headed his way
kurapikai says he must stay away from
the troop so they can sense his killing
intent so gon must give him enough time
to use his chains
squala exits the room enters an elevator
the whole time the troop knowing his
exact movements because of the scarlet
eyes copy the troop rushed for the hotel
the oreo unable to follow because of
traffic
gon and kora pika go on foot
kilua learns of this as well and follows
along the troops sends this and nobunaga
pakanota and kortopi go on ahead to
follow squala kralo machi and shizuku
confront the three the three hide
instantly kurapika enraged is about to
use his chains when gohan and killua
give themselves up they tie up bone and
kiluah believing they're connected with
kora pika gon asks why they kill people
and crawlow can only give confusing
rambling answers
sqwalla is frozen with fear with
nobunamba in front of his car and
pakinoda pointing a gun to his head
pakone breaks squala's arm during
questioning as squala says he had no
idea kuropika is the chain user she uses
her powers to find out about elisa and
squala becomes furious but in an instant
nope removes his head elisa suddenly has
a strange feeling
pakinoda uses memory bomb and then
ability to shoot thoughts in people's
heads on nobunaga and cortopi to give
them a clear image of what kora pika
looks like
naturally nobunage gets excited wanting
his revenge as gohan and killua are
captured by phantom troop crawlow orders
the rest of the members to meet up at
hotel when the troop arrives at the
hotel the oreo is seen sitting in the
lobby he suddenly picks up his phone and
pretends to call someone later it is
revealed that leoria was trying to relay
a message to gon and kilua about their
plan
the boys quickly comprehend the message
and do as he said pakinota nobunaga and
cortopia arrive there nobody is
surprised in seeing the two again and
thinks that they have changed their
minds about joining the troop he asked
them to be friends with him kiluah
refuses and states that he does not want
to see their faces as he turns away and
closes his eyes gone realizes that if
they do that won't seem suspicious for
them to close their eyes to adjust it
when the lights go out
crawlow asks pakinota to check on them
once again
she does as he says and approaches them
since there is still one minute left
gohan and kiluah have to buy time before
pacquano can check on them
kilowatt starts saying that her
abilities won't work since they are
innocent this however works perfectly as
planned right after pacquira knows the
truth the lights go out and killua
breaks free from machi's thread and
breaks packrun of his left arm followed
by gone kicking her chin
machi then pulls out the thread which
tied gone's arms to prevent him from
escaping
killua tries to set gone free by killing
machi but his claws end up trapped
within her muscles making him unable to
move and captured by machi gone then
tries to save his friend but is caught
by nobunaga instead
suddenly sora is thrown from the outside
with a letter tied on it as they realize
that their boss is gone nobunaga decides
to open the letter the letter is from
korapika and nobunaga gives it to
pakinota it says that if she talks about
the boy's memories he will kill crawlow
she then remains silent to prevent the
boss from being killed the room suddenly
goes bright again not long after that
finks faiton and schalner come for help
when they are discussing the situation
finks suddenly gets a call from
koratpika
he says that he will give three demands
and they must obey them or else the
leader will be killed korapika asked to
talk to pakinomura and orders her to
meet up at the place he designated he
then tells nobody that the rest of the
members should go back to the hideout
after that he gives directions to
pacquinoda regarding the place where
they will meet shortly after that she
goes to the set place alone meanwhile at
the truth's hideout hisoka is seeing
smiling and says then is the perfect
chance to fight crawlow but if he leaves
crolo will die he then picks up his
phone and asks illumi for help the end
of part 8 be sure to subscribe and hit
the notification bell to not miss the
next part